what's the story hopper what's this
you're teaching us
sifting through the bull crap because
there's been so much
what's the truth now hopper do you think
it's worth the look fixing revisionist
history
from all your school textbooks get the
scoop now hopper
fix the lies and fails sniffing out the
[ __ ] it's hopper on the trail come
on hopper
what's the stormy heartburn
[Music]
what's the story hopper
[Music]
catch the [ __ ] hopper
[Music]
once upon a time in the 80s the media
and governments of the world warned of
an impending catastrophe
one that could end civilization as we
know it the epidemic
of hiv aids
yes in the 1980s and early 90s the
message was clear
no one was safe
from the silent non-killer that is aids
aids oh no
many people had the wolf pulled over
their eyes with this hoax but with the
media a flutter over the latest doomsday
scenario
activists were quick to vilify skeptics
and reasonable doubters when the city of
new york estimated that 400 000
residents had aids the commissioner
himself john c joseph said that the
estimate was actually less than half
that
little did he know that he lit a powder
keg
leaders of aids organizations and social
activist groups accused him of
minimizing the crisis
and staged a sit-in demanding that he
resign it turns out that he was entirely
correct
but no matter
the tone had been set
in a hyperly politicized climate
lobbyists dug in their heels setting the
stage for the silent non-killer aids to
become the single most researched funded
disease in the modern history of america
despite it being a statistical non-risk
factor we demand more money to combat
this horrible disease which contrary to
popular belief afflicts people of all
shapes sizes and sexual orientations
only that wasn't true at all
statistically the cdc puts a
heterosexual american's chance of
contracting aids at zero percent
with 92 percent of all cases stemming
directly from male to male sexual
contact and the majority of the
remainder are coming from intravenous
drug use but clawing at the hundreds of
millions of dollars in government grants
fear mongering ran rampant with
statistics deliberately being
misreported in fact one of the most
cited landmark studies which reported
over 573 000 aids cases among no risk
victims the conductors were later caught
funding their data having to reverse
over 46 of the non-risk factor victims
to be reclassified
but by that point
the damage had been done but i know it
doc i just know it mr hopper i can
assure you you do not have aids but all
my hair is falling out that's just your
summer coat but my bars fell off hopper
you had those surgically removed five
years ago oh
[Music]
but hindsight is 20 20. in the moment
everyone believed the silent non-killer
aids to truly be an epidemic
even though the chances of contracting
it short of anal sex with gay strangers
while shooting heroin was statistically
non-existent
matter of fact the chances of a straight
person contracting hiv in the modern
world is four and ten thousand per
exposure
meaning that if a man were even married
to an hiv infected bride he'd have to
engage in intercourse with her an
average of ten thousand separate
occasions to expose himself to
contracting aids
i have to do what
but for decades among all the
pandemonium none of this mattered math
statistical realities were all tossed
aside for fear of being called a bigot
and because tom hanks made a movie i
don't see a case
oh tom hanks you're truly our talent
why'd you have to do the vinci code
well through the 1990s funding continued
to soar for the entirely preventable
disease while countless americans
including millions of children died of
diseases helplessly entirely out of
their control with actual mortality
rates
but they didn't have a celebrity
awareness campaign and received a
fraction of the funding yes the aids
epidemic hoax is one of the greatest
ever perpetrated in the american public
and one that inadvertently cost millions
of lives of actual victims
as with all great mistakes
a valuable lesson to be learned
you too can help save children's lives
and stop stealing the research dollars
by taking these simple steps
to easily avoid the silent non-killer so
really as long as you're not having
unprotected anal sex with strangers or
sharing needles you have nothing to
worry about
also stop biting hobos oh
cause i did bite at him that one time
wait are you saying hobos or hormones no
no hobos don't bite hobos okay you're
saying hobos or homos i'm i'm still not
clear no
hobos you know what just just
played safe don't bite either
[Music]
hey if you like this video subscribe by
clicking the button that says subscribe
if you're not aware of it now there's no
way you're learning the internet at this
point i'm not going to help you but this
was clipped from my daily show available
exclusively to lotto with credit.com mug
club members if your student military or
veteran entering that promo code it's
less than six dollars a month and you
get daily content no more clips plus
this hand etched mug oh i just when i
feel it i gotta chill like on the inside